hallo arthur wie geht es dir hallo
arthur wie geht es dir
hey mary sehr gut danke schön dich zu
sehen
danke möchtest du etwas trinken
danke möchtest du etwas trinken ja gerne
ja gerne
ich kann es kaum erwarten deine
geschichte zu hören
erzähl mal ich kann es kaum erwarten
deine geschichte zu hören erzähl mal ja
ich werde dir alles darüber erzählen
ja ich werde dir alles darüber erzählen
entschuldigung entschuldigung
hallo wie kann ich ihnen helfen
was möchtest du trinken was möchtest du
trinken
ich hätte gern einen cappuccino ohne
zucker bitte ich hätte gern einen
cappuccino ohne zucker bitte darf es
noch etwas sein
darf es noch etwas sein nein danke das
ist alles nein danke das ist alles ja
zwei cappuccinos bitte ja zwei
cappuccinos bitte möchten sie ihren
cappuccino mit oder ohne zucker möchten
sie ihren cappuccino mit oder ohne
zucker mit zucker bitte danke mit zucker
bitte danke bitte schön
ich komme gleich wieder bitteschön
ich komme gleich wieder vielen dank
vielen dank erzähl mir bitte wie du
millionär wurde ist so erzähl mir bitte
wie du millionär wurde ist hier zwei
cappuccinos einer mit zucker und der
andere ohne hier zwei cappuccinos einer
mit zucker und der andere ohne danke
vielen dank
danke vielen dank bitte bitte
ich war seit meiner kindheit immer ein
guter geschäftsmann
ich habe in der schule jede art von
gegenständen verkauft ich habe in der
schule jede art von gegenständen
verkauft ich war nicht so gut ihn
verkaufen
ich war nicht so gut ihn verkaufen als
ich in der oberstufe war habe ich ein
paar kleider gekauft und sie im internet
angeboten
als ich in der oberstufe war habe ich
ein paar kleider gekauft und sie im
internet angeboten
ich habe die kleider sehr schnell
verkauft
das war eine sehr gute idee
das war eine sehr gute idee danke danke
ich habe meine eigene website erstellt
um kleidung und barren im internet zu
verkaufen
ich habe meine eigene webseite erstellt
um kleidung und waren im internet zu
verkaufen und das unternehmen begann
gewinne zu erwirtschaften
und das unternehmen begann gewinne zu
erwirtschaften
ich habe gemerkt dass es ein profitables
geschäft ist
geschäft ist also bin ich nach china
gereist und günstigere waren zu bekommen
also bin ich nach china gereist und
günstigere waren zu bekommen
hat dir die chinesische kultur gefallen
hat der die chinesische kultur gefallen
ich habe sie geliebt ich habe sie
geliebt die leute waren sehr nett die
leute waren sehr nett
als ich am flughafen in china ankam war
meine kontaktperson die mir die ware
verkauft hatte bereits dort als ich am
flughafen in china ankam war meine
kontaktperson die mir die ware verkauft
hatte bereits dort
er hat mich mit seinem auto abgeholt und
mich zum mittagessen eingeladen
dann hat er mir die stadt gezeigt dann
hat er mir die stadt gezeigt wir sind
entlang der großen chinesischen mauer
spaziert wir sind entlang der großen
chinesischen mauer spaziert wir haben
chinesische spezialitäten probiert wir
haben chinesische spezialitäten probiert
und ich habe im besten hotel der stadt
übernachtet und ich habe im besten hotel
der stadt übernachtet
es war eine erstaunliche reise ich habe
die ware bekommen die ich wollte es war
eine erstaunliche reise ich habe die
ware bekommen die ich wollte dann bin
ich mit der ware in die schweiz
zurückgekehrt dann bin ich mit der ware
in die schweiz zurückgekehrt und du
reist jedes mal nach china um waren zu
kaufen und du reist jedes mal nach china
um waren zu kaufen ja ich reise alle
drei monate
ja ich reise alle drei monate
wie schön die verkäufe stiegen von tag
zu tag
die verkäufe stiegen von tag zu tag
also habe ich beschlossen zu expandieren
und filialen im ganzen land zu eröffnen
bald hatte ich in meinen geschäften
bereits jedes produkt das tue dir
vorstellen kannst
bald hatte ich in meinen geschäften
bereits jedes produkt das studio
vorstellen kannst
die gewinne die ich erzählt habe habe
ich in aktien an der börse investiert
nach und nach wuchs diese anteile und
sie brachten mir mehr gewinnen
nach und nach wuchsen diese anteile und
mit den gewinnen aus dem aktienmarkt und
meinen geschäften habe ich beschlossen
ein autohaus zu gründen
mit den gewinnen aus dem aktienmarkt und
meinen geschäften habe ich beschlossen
ein autohaus zu gründen
ich habe die autos aus japan importiert
dadurch konnte ich meine gewinner
steigern
innerhalb eines jahres hatte ich
landesweit zehn auto filialen innerhalb
eines jahres hatte ich landesweit zehn
auto filialen
ich habe mit den händlern sehr gut
zusammengearbeitet
unglaublich unglaublich
ich bin dank der einkünfte aus meinen
geschäften viel gereist und habe viele
länder kennengelernt
ich bin dank der einkünfte aus meinen
geschäften viel gereist und habe viele
länder kennengelernt und auf einer
dieser reisen habe ich beschlossen dass
ich meine eigene flugzeugflotte haben
möchte
und auf einer dieser reisen habe ich
beschlossen dass ich meine eigene
flugzeugflotte haben möchte also habe
ich mir flugzeuge besorgt und meine
eigene fluggesellschaft gegründet
also habe ich mir flugzeuge besorgt und
meine eigene fluggesellschaft gegründet
und so bin ich an all das geld gekommen
dass ich heute habe und so bin ich an
all das geld gekommen dass ich heute
habe was für eine tolle geschichte
was für eine tolle geschichte ich
wünschte ich hätte das glück dass du
hattest
ich wünschte ich hätte das glück dass du
hattest nun erzählen mir von deinem
leben nun erzählen mir von deinem leben
[Musik]
als kind habe ich in einer stadt ganz in
der nähe von hier gelebt als kind habe
ich in einer stadt ganz in der nähe von
hier gelebt meine eltern haben in einem
supermarkt gearbeitet
meine eltern haben in einem supermarkt
gearbeitet
als ich in der schule war mochte ich
zahlen
ich habe das gymnasium abgeschlossen und
bin an die uni gegangen
dort habe ich betriebswirtschaft
studiert dort habe ich
betriebswirtschaft studiert ich habe
mein bachelorstudium abgeschlossen
ich habe mein bachelorstudium
abgeschlossen und ich habe begonnen in
einem bauunternehmen zu arbeiten und ich
habe begonnen in einem bauunternehmen zu
arbeiten
ich habe dort fünf jahre lang gearbeitet
später beschloss ich mich zu
spezialisieren
neben der arbeit habe ich studiert
neben der arbeit habe ich studiert meine
eltern sind jetzt pensioniert meine
eltern sind jetzt pensioniert heute
leben sie von ihrer rente
heute leben sie von ihrer rente und ich
helfe ihnen auch finanziell und ich
helfe ihnen auch finanziell
weißt du ich suche jemanden der mine
unternehmen führt weißt du ich suche
jemanden der mine unternehmen führt ich
glaube ich habe sie bereits gefunden
ich glaube ich habe sie bereits gefunden
das kann nicht sein das kann nicht sein
wirklich wirklich natürlich natürlich
ich möchte dass du mit mir
zusammenarbeitet
ich freue mich sehr
danke für die gelegenheit ich freue mich
sehr
danke für die gelegenheit
möchtest du gratis online deutsch lernen
mehr als 200 video lektionen abonniere
unseren kanal möchtest du gratis online
deutsch lernen mehr als 200 video
lektionen abonniere unseren kanal